こんにちははじめしゃちょーで率直に言いますタバコが吸いたい
まあお願いの24の男になってくるところなんかこういう男らしたっていうのもと
目指してきたのは母でしょうが男らした
だから氏造形とかつけたんですけどこれから僕後のほとなのを男性になるためには
もっと男らしくなりたくてまあ男らしいからもうタバコしかない症っていうわけでえと
タバコを吸います
と言いたいところなんですけども僕ちょっと喘息持ちでタバコ吸うと喘息発作が出
ちゃって0吸えない体なんですよえっなんかコンビニでバイトしてる時
art 中ですよてょしてる時に先輩から一本立っを変えてコースデーパティ1本打っ
た瞬間っっ
ってなってもうそれでちょっとメタボな気分にだか弱くてタバコを吸いたいなとか言っ
てるんですけどもたばこ嫌いなんですよだって体に悪いんでしょ
体に悪いの動画できれば避けたいんで喘息発作も出るしタバコ吸ってる人の近くに置い
たくないくらいタバコを直地雷なんですけども
タバコ吸いたいという矛盾な掃除ておりますはかで体に害がなければ炭鉱を吸いたいと
思ってるんですよね
選んだとかだこれでやりたいわけですよ僕はでもタバコは体によくないからやりたく
ないそんなの上に遺跡から訪れたはいこちら
これ名前がわからない日だしぶって言うか箱っぽい人たちらしいですちょっと調べます
あーなんかタバコ吸いたいって言ってるんですけどもあのタバコは絶対やめたほうが
いいですぼくの周り吸ってる人結構助けダメなんですけどもみんな揃っていう
のはもう末で辞めた方がいいみたいなお腹向け立てなくなるらしいんで電子タバコどの
ストアのかなこれこれをちょっとこれホントすごいですよニコチンタールとか有害物質
が入ってないらしいですこれとか見てねー吸っていいのかなそこが結構ポイントだと
思いますあーなるほどねなんか逆知恵袋で見たんですけどニコチンタールが入ってい
ないからいい方ではないなシーンですけども未成年館でタバコっぽいの吸ってるとか側
に怪しいと思うので実はさせ
得られるらしいのガンマンなんかよろしくないみたいです2000年の人はやめておき
ましょうねて僕は大の大人なのでこの全く一切無駄位のたばこを吸いまこれすごい言っ
てよニコチンタールを含んでいないんだか栄養栄養が栄養が a 4 a 8が入って
るってホンマや有害物質じゃなくて栄養が入ってるあつのタイプもすごいだがいろいろ
フルーティーな奴がありますねすごいです
ね電子タバコっていうアレらしいんですけどはいとりあえず今あのこんなこと言って
ますけど本当にたばこ嫌いでたボコってる人いたら部屋から出るんですよ立てたよく
考えてみりゃあんなんかた額を多分結構有名な話なんですけども主流煙と副流煙って
いうのがあって他の濃さっている人より周りにいる人の方がガーになる確率が上がる
みたいな光景
人ができたからもう吸ってる自分より周りの人のほうが金なんか人名に地球犯される
みたいかあんまりよろしくないんですよな人に迷惑かけないならいいと思うんですけど
もう周りにいる人にそういうちょっとあればちょっとよろしくないなとか思ってしま
うっています集まりサボ好きじゃないんですけどこれならいいかもね煙草を吸っ
ててるこれをしたいんで僕はちょっと2にらヴァニラ vanilla スってみます
おおおおあぁ押され寄せれ
こんなデザインになっております文房具屋さんのねりけしの匂いがするぞ
ああもうこの持っている手がかっこいいもこの帝人向けのそういいましてですねなんで
未成年の方は2000年の傾い方でやってますがない方が良いと思われますねこっちん
とカタールとかが入ってないので安全が舗装された成分と天然成分のみを使用してい
ます安全だ俺もう6れてコープスマスターできる理由は倍早くみんなに自慢したいだし
前
本当に表現緊張するんだけどで上げます
[音楽]
うん払ったらバローえっ
あっはバ p 匂いやいい匂い言うな
うん
[音楽]
やべやべまじかっけーじゃんまじかっけーのはって
パ
焼きそばパン買ってこいややれやれ目楽器屋の方へ
ハッハー
ん
小矢部ぜベイじゃねーぞまず1次あのかしてるんだ買う
貼っ待ってるわけば軽率らツアーのそう言うとかで有るならね
ねぇ
me
バッハ